all right what up cisgender ladies we're
not that involved in the YouTube world
all right
that being said there was a video from
PewDiePie that kind of popped out to me
and so we're gonna do it a look
hello I wanted to talk seriously and
honestly for a moment about my thoughts
on what's been going on for the past
couple months and hopefully you you can
get a better understanding of my
perspective I think it's time to end
that subscribe to PewDiePie movement or
mean hopefully it's something people can
understand is when you have 90 million
people riled up about something you're
bound to get a few degenerate
yeah that's pretty accurate I think if
any movement know anything we have them
in the dance community we have a music
world and comedy world is degenerates
that's steal money from other people
like anything I didn't want hateful acts
to overpower all these amazing things
that people were doing all these cool
and positive things but then something
happened that I don't think anyone would
have predicted the Christchurch shooter
said subscribe to PewDiePie
I don't really the respect for the
families and victims involved I chose
not to address it any further than on
Twitter where I disavowed the actions
taken that day and I gave my sincerest
condolences to everyone affected to have
my name associated with something so
unspeakably vile has affected me in more
ways than I let shown I just didn't want
to address it right away and I didn't
want to give the terrorists any more
attention I didn't want to make it about
me because I don't think it has anything
to do with me to put it plainly I didn't
want hate to win but it's clear to me
now the sub subscribe to PewDiePie
movement should have ended then I
understood I understand where he came
from with that it's just it's [ __ ] up
that it comes like that but I understand
why the movement is just bigger than you
in ages
the movement is bigger than him and now
what comes out of it is it's not
something that he likes and many scenes
he just does he have to take that he did
this PewDiePie I have to take a step in
the step and he's it he's doing right
now to be like yeah and let's just just
end it I don't think he has to do it
it's good that he does it so by doing
all this
most of his followers are gonna follow
him and they'll be like yeah that's put
an end to all this and it's just gonna
die down it's just in the process of
things dying down for him not to be
linked to more negative stuff cuz it
started be from little stuff that was
negative to bigger stuff to bigger stuff
the bigger stuff are you just saying
he's just saying I'm not really having
fun with it so let's just let's just ill
I'm through with that I'm through with
that movement he's doing I started it
and now he's ending it I don't mind that
he sucked new he's with his rights do
whatever you want if it's not fun for
you stop doing that's fine I just think
the precedent and sends mentally to
other people is a bad one you know mean
preach have our own YouTube channels
some of our idiot subscribers start
shooting up schools I'm not stopping the
YouTube channel because nothing I do or
say encourages that so why should I be
responsible for their actions
no there's people with problems out
there who wanted to disrupt the world
and make this uncomfortable for everyone
and by you ending this I think he's
succeeding that was was part of his
manifesto he wanted to start some kind
of race war he wanted you know to really
initiate a lot of negative energy and
now that you're ending get it just seems
like yeah you know it's a victory for
him that in by in taking this action
you're actually encouraging and you're
empowering negative people to make a
change cuz if one guy with some guns can
end a worldwide movement like this with
one action what's to stop the next time
be like yo you know what I want to be
important in life too whether it's
PewDiePie whether it's a government
start to enact 30 laws whether it's
Muslims now carrying guns in every month
whether it's PewDiePie ending his fun
campaign all of these things are things
he was hoping for people's changing
things for negative things is what may
make things more secure no no not
necessarily
or or it gives people a sense of
security doesn't mean it's the right
thing to do or it doesn't mean the most
effective thing to do to act out of
emotion and to act just because
something happened doesn't mean you're
taking the effective right I'm not
saying no but you saying that people
that when there's negative things that
happen people take them steps to that
towards that so as the negative things
that happen and they change they change
stuff to different things people change
different things stories negative things
that happen not always not always but
sometimes they do and one of my hope
is is that when you take that action and
you don't think it through thoroughly
and you don't understand the principles
you're upholding you're actually
negatively impacting everybody okay
meaning 9/11 happened they had the
reaction everything where they went on
to Iraq doesn't mean it was the right
thing to do but they did react
sometimes we react negatively to things
because we have to desire to change
things that may not necessarily be the
most sensible course an action to take
the same way because a mass shooter says
PewDiePie and now he stops his entire
movement doesn't mean it's the most
sensible action to take you know I
understand what he's trying to do he's
trying to go towards the side of empathy
and understanding but it doesn't mean
that this is effective you know because
now he's you know I don't think he's
taking responsibility but in a way he is
for the actions of a few and he feels
like he has to take actions because of
that you know but that's also the same
logic that the left disavow when it
comes to Muslims right they feel like
Muslims shouldn't have to be responsible
for what a few radicals do or whatever
that is their rhetoric basically what
you're saying is just it's not just with
emotion let's think about [ __ ] the thing
to do also just think about what our
actions are saying in terms of our
values you know and the values that
we're projecting outwards because
today's PewDiePie tomorrow could be yes
oh it will be
imagine if Martin Luther King was
responsible for every [ __ ] idiot
person at his [ __ ] rallies nothing
would ever get done we cannot allow the
actions of a few to dictate the morals
and the values that we push forward as
in society all this does all this to say
I don't think we're responsible for what
happens in our YouTube set target
section and I think the problem right
now even with YouTube is that they're
making people responsible yeah I hate to
comments yeah which to me is wack
because you're getting if you're getting
thousands of comments every day and it's
going quick can't read a thousand
comments a day no and then we don't even
get we don't even have we don't even
have that many subscribers like that no
and I can't read all everything that's
happening every time that would that's a
full-time job that's a full-time done
page dog that is and there's people that
will use that against you where they if
they know that that's the policy they'll
start to post hundreds and hundreds of
comments that are very like suspect yeah
and then over reported YouTube like he's
not taking care of it now your
[ __ ] that a job you know what I mean
there's there shady [ __ ] like that so we
shouldn't be responsible for that kind
of stuff that would scare me well III
just they're doing right now on YouTube
and it's it's not going well for a lot
of the creators and I think as a society
and the world in general we're having
knee-jerk reactions to a lot of these
negative events and that's actually
fueling the encouragement of these
people to do it more often
mass shooters are at an all-time high
right now because they know the nor
notoriety that they're gonna get
lone-wolf and if you guys keep taking
actions and keep encouraging these
people who feel insignificant their
lives to feel significant through these
means then yeah I'm not gonna be
surprised when it happens more what is
PewDiePie the end of this movement
what if someone goes on another mass
shooting and still so subscribe to
PewDiePie he didn't do anything all they
did was stop a movement of positivity
for the most part that you know people
are gonna still keep on saying negative
things you can't control
what degenerates are gonna do too late
[ __ ] okay too late no you let it
go you let it go I didn't do something
interesting that this is the first video
from PewDiePie that ends up on the
trending page
personally I don't understand how the
trending page works I don't think
anybody does no it's not it's not a way
to work please select a few things there
I believe it's layers there's a few
things that are they there's a few
things that are alerted that are
trending and then from that they select
what the official yeah cuz there's a
bunch of thing that he we could have
been trending but nothing happened we're
gonna suppress this [ __ ] right
there so whatever which I think is
unfortunate because it kind of kills a
little bit my food but just like
PewDiePie belongs time is having like
viral videos and then nothing and the
one times I [ __ ] up huge it was like
yeah you did just put it right up on
trending [ __ ]